What we have here today is a sweet demonstration of the sampling distribution of
the mean, otherwise known as the distribution of sample means. We've laid out 48
plates each with a bag of M&Ms on it. We're going to dump out these M&Ms,
there's Dr. Rogers doing so, across all 48 plates. This is a very tedious
process so we sped things up a little bit to make it go faster. Once we have all
the M&M's dumped out we're going to separate them by color. We are interested in
the blue M&M's. Of course, you could pick any color if you wanted. You could use
orange or green or yellow, but we've chosen blue. Once we've separated out the
blue M&M's we're going to count them. There I am helping along, Dr. Rogers got
tired of me sitting over in the corner just watching, so he recruited my help.
Once we have the blue M&Ms sorted, we're going to be interested in the average
number of blue M&Ms per bag, or per plate in this case. And what we're going to
do then is take random sample of n equals 5 and compute an average. Once we've
done that we're going to do that 50 times, taking 50 random samples, each with n
equals 5 plates. Then we're going to construct a histogram. That histogram will
be the distribution of sample means. Remember that the central limit theorem
says, that the distribution of sample means will be approximately normal, and
we'll have an expected value of the mean equal to the population mean. Now the
true population mean we've computed by taking all blue M&Ms across all plates
and divided them by 48, the number of plates. Remember the central limit theorem
also says that the standard deviation of the distribution of sample means is
equal to sigma the population standard deviation divided by the square root of
the sample size. Let's see how the data turned out